yeah welcome to the second talk today so
the next talk is by mccand and he's
going to tell us about separation of
quantum and classical using the k-fold
fold action function
right uh can everyone hear me
right
so
the stock is partly based on work with
nikhil who is somehow convincing me to
give all the talks and he's not here
uh
and I say partly because I thought it
would be nicer to do
a survey of all the ideas that go into
it so I'll mostly
not be talking about what we did there's
only a small part about it but just how
this line of work evolved
I wanted a friendly title for this
thought so I don't know whether this you
know
keeps that goal
but if not I asked shared GPT to
generate another title
and I it's really really good so
should
this will be the unofficial title for
the talk
doesn't endorse this
I don't know he was in Germany so he
probably
from the entire lecture what what was it
from GPT just the title or the entire
lecture so I gave it the previous title
and asked to generate a new title
all right
so this whole line of work is sort of
motivated by understanding this we go
like in what ways someone comes
Computing is more powerful than Plus
what are the problems that are easy for
quantum computers but hard for classical
ones
it's a very very big goal and today the
stock
we're going to look at this goal through
this problem
let me call it for K4 Fourier
correlation for now
and as complexity theorists we like to
abbreviate everything
so let me just call it cable for
relation which is the name that's got
then uh Andres gave it when they came up
with this uh you know 2018.
and sometimes for some results here you
can also consider variance variance of
this problem or composed with other
functions which is what this and Friends
refers to
so before telling you what this problem
is let me just tell you a little bit
about the context
so this problem is something that's very
efficiently computable by Quantum
algorithms so I'm not going to go too
much into what the model is for Quantum
Computing but you can solve it with just
K over two queries so K is just the
constant in the stock so two or three or
hundred
so it doesn't depend on input size
so if K is 2 you can solve this problem
with one Quantum query
and not only that sort of this problem
is also like bqp complete so it's
not in just a number of queries but in
terms of running time also you can
efficiently solve with the quantum
computer
so in call I mean with regards to the
previous question of separating Quantum
also classical I mean there are two
distinct goals one is to show that
there's a Quantum algorithm for a
problem and the other is to prove uh
lower lower amount for classical
algorithms and in this case
we sort of know that this this problem
is easy for quantum computers in fact
it's sort of btp complete so it's sort
of like the canonical easy problem for
Quantum Computing in some sense
so it's sort of proposed as a candidate
for many Quantum classical separations
and it has been used in the last five
years to prove some very interesting
results
for instance you might have most people
have probably heard of this Oracle
separation for dqp and pH uh by Iran and
Abhishek
and
for that it's used
as a base case like two full formation
problem
uh in my paper with nikhail and also
this parallel work by shares of studies
it was used to show that uh to show
maximal separation between Quantum
classical query complexity and
communication protocols in another paper
by Anderson in grab and crutch power it
was used to show some
weird Oracle separations that are hard
to understand
and uh recently in a joint work with
crusher
we sort of used it to show an oracle
separation between classical
cryptography based on one-way functions
and Quantum photography so the problem
is sort of
uh
very useful for proving separate Quantum
classical separations and in some cases
even
separations for Quantum complexity
classes
so essentially that's all I'm going to
tell you
about the context of this problem I mean
there are many interesting Quantum
reasons to consider this problem
but this talk will be about how to prove
classical lower bounds for this problem
in fact we're going to prove a very
general result in terms of the Fourier
spectrum of
computational model
recall that if you have any
computational model on the hypercube you
can always write what it computes as a
polynomial of
polynomial indexed by subsets of one
through n
the coefficients of these polymers are
the Fourier coefficients and the
monomials are just products of all the
bits that are going to set
so the only fact about foreign
or bounded then the sum of squares of
all these coefficients is at most one
possibly that's the only thing you would
need
and what we prove this stock will sort
of generalize to
many different models uh all we need to
understand is that Fourier Spectrum in
some way
foreign
this lower bound there's sort of two
different concepts that come in two
different ideas
the first is that you forget growth
which is also useful in pseudonymous and
learning theory
and if you were uh here yesterday in
Korea's talk it was done like fractional
prgs
and uh
the second idea that comes in that's
also very interesting is Society of
Pathways analysis or stochastic process
analysis of cooling functions
and this is also I mean there's a whole
reading group on it so if you want to
learn more you should come to the
reading group
So the plan for this talk will be to
introduce what k44 ration is and then to
show how these ideas come in to prove
this logo
so let me tell you what the scaffold
formation problem is
so it's sort of a weird problem if you
haven't seen it before but
hopefully by the end of this talk would
make sense so the input to this problem
is
km bit string which is partitioned into
K Parts fan bibs
and the formulation of K is
uh
going to be a particular degree capable
that I'm going to tell you about in a
second that takes values between -1 and
1.
so this output surreal number is not the
you know decision problem
so to convert keto decision problem
we'll just do the usual thing
you just take a threshold so the value
of the polynomial is close to zero then
we'll say the function output rejects if
the value of the polynomial is far from
zero we say it accepts
so this is a promise problem based on
the value of this polynomial
and for this talk I will just mostly
focus on the case of two and three
uh and tell you what this polymer looks
like in these cases
so for two input is like two and bit
strain
the first part I will call Y X the
second part I'll call Y so these are end
with inputs
the formulation is basically this
bilinear form which is given by so you
take here how do I
so you take your vector Y which is the
length n plus minus 1 vector you
multiply it with the Matrix which is the
hard amount Matrix also the Fourier
transform Matrix so n by n Matrix where
N is a power uh so where all entries are
plus minus one over square root n is
orthogonal Matrix so just a rotation
and uh
so basically once you apply
and then you take the inner product with
this other Vector X after some non
validation
so to justify the name sort of if you
consider your vector y as a true table
of a Boolean function
and H of Y is the Fourier transform of
that function
and what you're measuring here is like
uh how correlated is the
one particular function X correlated
with the Fourier transform of the other
function y
and it should also be easy to see from
this form that this function always
takes values between minus one and one
because if you take the vector X over
square root 10 and Y over square root n
these are unit vectors in eucliding norm
and this is a matrix whose operator
normal at most one
so the outputs number between -1 and 1.
and it let me just expand this out so if
you expand it out in terms of the
monomials this is what the volume looks
like so it's a degree to polynomial
yeah x i j y a j and the entry of The
Matrix
might be easier to remember this graph
theoretically which might be important
for uh rest of the talk
to sort of consider this graph picture
so you label you consider bipartite
graph you label the monomials on the
left with X whenever else on the right
with Y and you add the label h i j on
this Edge and so for every Edge you
multiply all the labels that gives you
one monomial in this polynomial and you
sum up all the labels
so
and one thing that will not be very
important but I would like to point out
here
is that you can replace this edge with
any orthogonal Matrix you get some
different polynomial and that gives you
whole class of functions to work with in
the stock which is what this and friend
slippers do
so any questions
N is a power of two yeah always
not all of them may be efficiently
capitals
say whether when the value of this
polynomial is close to zero far from
zero so let's just try to understand
this a little bit
of the inputs
if each monomial is zero
and you can sort of show that the
variance of this polymer is very small
so typically the polynomial is very very
close to zero when you pick uniform
input
let's try to give you
another distribution which
takes large values and the green region
and for this
just try to compute expected value of
this polynomial under a new distribution
and for now
I will just pick X and Y to be instead
of bits I will take them to be gaussians
in N dimensions
as follows so you pick X
and Y to be two n dimensional gaussians
so gaussian in two n Dimensions left and
right side will be independent so there
is no correlation
between vertices on the left the
coordinates on the left and the
coordinates on the right and in between
the correlation is exactly what's the
label of this Edge
and why am I picking gaussians here
because for gaussians if you know that
meat and covariance you basically
determine the distribution so you don't
have to worry about higher order
correlations
so essentially this determines the
distribution
now if you compute the expected value of
this polynomial under this green
distribution
the expectation of x i and y j is just h
i j
and H entry is 1 over square root n so
the expected value of this polynomial is
one
sort of I've cheated so far because I've
plugged in value that could be much much
larger than one
so here the next idea that's probably
we're very used to in DCS is the idea of
rounding so you can take like the sign
of the gaussian uh or do other kinds of
rounding and uh you can still show that
value of this polynomial is kind of very
very large in expectations
the thresholds here will just be some
constants in this thought
any questions
so this is a two-fold formulation
problem let me tell you what the three
full formation problem is and I will
stop after that I will not go to
fourfold
so so now the input is a three and bit
string x y z
and the polynomial is sort of uh
looks like this it's hard to ex you know
just read it off from the expression but
a graph related picture is actually much
easier to explain
so now you have three sets of variables
so it's a tripartite graph label the
variables x y z you put the labels h i j
on the edges
and for each path from left to right you
multiply all the labels and you add up
that gives you monomial and you add them
up so that's what this problem is
and this fundamental is also bounded and
now the goal is to decide between these
cases the red or green
and uh
so again the uniform distribution is
very close to zero even for this
polynomial
let me tell you a distribution which
takes large values so a little bit
non-trivial to describe because if you
pick the distribution we had previously
you picked X and Y to be some correlated
gaussian according to this
uh the structure and if you pick Z
independently then the value of this
monomial will be zero so you need to
enforce that X I mean each path is sort
of correlated
in order to do this
we'll take two two gaussians for these
copies so X and A will be gaussians
correlation x h i j and b and Z will be
gaussian and in the middle you will glue
these gaussians together by taking
pointwise products
so
you have a two n dimensional vectors you
take pointwise products and that will
give you y
so it's
sort of
and now you can compute the expected
value of this polymer well this y j will
split into a J A and B J and the
expected value of the level is still
again one
and if you want to get uh
Distribution on both
uh you again do the usual trick of
rounding it will give you large values
so for the rest of this talk you can
sort of think of this problem as
distinguishing these two distributions
one is the uniform distribution which is
another distribution which takes large
values for these formulas I will call it
four related Fourier correlated
and you can think of this as a just the
problem of distinguishing these two
distributions with your computation
models
questions
so just make sure I understand x a b and
z are all gaussians yeah so X and K are
correlated now since next continents are
independent a coordinates in between
just like the same thing as previous
name blg are independent copy and you
will glue
I would have guessed to see it again so
Ki as well
First full symmetry rotation symmetry
this coordinates is that just like not
interesting for some reason
yes probably not yeah I think you can
probably that doesn't add anything it
doesn't add any hardness to the problems
so we come to the next part of this talk
uh they find this problem hopefully
you're clear on what this problem is how
do you prove classical lower bounds in
terms of the Fourier spectrum of this
function
where it's a little bit abstract let me
set a concrete goal for this talk
which will be to prove sort of
at any decision tree
or even a parity decision tree for this
problem makes n to the 1 minus 1 over K
queries
so decision tree model is sort of
following computation model you query a
bit of your input depending on its value
which is another bit to query until you
hit one of the leaves and you output
whatever is written on the leaves
and Battery decision tree you do a
similar thing but you're allowed to
query parities instead of just kids
and so this model the battery decision
tree model is more powerful because it
can you know always just query single
variables here
the same bounce folds for both of these
uh okay
and in this model sort of you can
compute any function if you query n Bits
if you query the entire input you can
compute any function because you know
this value so n is the maximal amount of
queries you need to compute any Boolean
function of this model
so here n to the 1 minus 1 over k
and K is 2 square root n and SK grows
larger and larger it becomes closer and
closer to one so you need like maximal
amount of queries in order to solve this
problem as for this the results and says
and this is in some sense the best
possible result you can prove so this is
the best possible separation between
Quantum and classical
but if uh for I mean so now we can just
remember that there is a randomized
algorithm that matches the same upper
bound
yes
and in this approximate equality I am
hiding locks at Poly log factors which I
will do the rest of the stuff
decision tree result here was proven by
uh in my paper with nickel but also for
a variant of this problem by shares of
storage
and the factory decision tree result
follows from the theorem that we're
going to see in this talk and result by
Gary Stalin who on the Fourier spectrum
of patriotic entries
yeah so yeah so it also holds for
randomization trees and randomized
factories increase yeah
oh no I mean E3 yes
do you say something about it
the normalization
the one over n or for the rounding
okay I don't follow what you mean by
that
you mean the rounding or the non-viation
is so that the value is between minus
one and one and the rounding
these thresholds are always going to be
some constants that are a little bit far
apart
it's quite depends on K but for K plus
two and three it sounds possible
and okay again I just wanted to mention
the parity District result because it
follows from the theorem we're going to
look at but mostly I'm going to focus on
just decision trees just probably the
simplest classical computational model
you can think of
and if you view this the function that's
computed by decision tree as a Boolean
function which is a polynomial the
degree of that polynomial is the number
of queries that this decision tree makes
or the depth of this polona of this tree
will lower bound one very nice concept
that comes in is the concept of Fourier
growth uh so you need some way of
distinguishing
the k-fold foliation problem for
instance K3 this is just the degree
three polynomial
and what I've said before is you have a
very huge decision tree whose degree is
possibly polymer millionaire so why
can't it compute this degree three
problem
so you need to find some sort of
difference uh property that
differentiate these two things and one
possible property you can hope for if
this is a very denseful novel it has all
possible monomials you can think of with
some coefficients
no on the other hand if you look at a
decision tree
let me call this function f is the
corresponding function that it computes
you could hope that okay even if this
computes like a degree N Pull on uh and
fauna will or degree almost time
polynomial it sort of computes the
sparse polynomial in some sense
because if it does then okay possibly
there is a hope of differentiating these
two things
and one way of one proxy for sparsity
often is sort of the L1 Norm L one of
your Fourier spectrum is small in the
sum of absolute value of your Fourier
coefficient is kind of small then you
can say that your polynomial is part
but here this Fourier growth concept is
a sort of more refined version of that
instead of looking at the entire Fourier
Spectrum you just look at each level L
consider all monomials of degree L and
you look at the alpha Norm of that
so the sum of absolute value of query
coefficients at level l we'll call it
the Fourier weight at level l
and one
so if this Fourier weight is small
you're basically uh
sort of sparse some sense
and one basic Factor remember is that
the Fourier coefficient is just the
value of the derivative evaluated at
zero
and so this is if this quantity is small
it's also saying that the elect order
derivatives are sort of small
so I mean just for sanity check let's
make sure that these two quantities are
very different so if you consider this
capable formulation problem so this K is
not an index anymore it's the weight K
is the key for the k for correlation
it's uh Korea weight is quite large on
the other hand the case level Fourier
weight of the decision tree as we're
going to see later
sort of scale first number of queries it
makes so the depth to the power K over
2. so the number of queries is very very
small then you're going to have a big
difference
so there is a huge gap there so let's uh
it passes the first sanity check
but uh the degree of this polymer on the
right can be very large so what about
higher Fourier levels why don't they
help us
and so this will become clear in this
slide hopefully so how do you use this
to prove lower bounds for this problem
the call that our goal is to show that a
decision tree cannot distinguish these
two distributions
so let F be whatever function the
decision tree computes so if it cannot
distinguish them then if the expected
value under these two distributions
should be very very small
so it shouldn't be able to tell these
values apart
the expected value under the uniform
distribution is just uh
constant Fourier coefficient or the
constant terminal per model because all
the other terms go to zero
so you can write it as the in terms of
the Fourier Spectrum as the
pre-coefficient times the uh
expected value of this monomial under
this distribution which is a moment of
this distribution
let me just take absolute values here
everywhere
and let me now also for each L pick out
the maximum moment you can have
at that level
we get this expression
and I can see that the first term here
is actually the Fourier weighted level l
and the second term here is the maximum
moment you can have
at level l
so now if your moments Decay fast enough
and your Fourier weight doesn't increase
fast enough hopefully you can bound
these two quantities uh you can prove
that this this quantity is small
in fact this approach you can make it
work if you consider random variance of
correlation instead of the hardware
Matrix the definition of correlation
just pick a random orthogonal Matrix
and you can use this approach to prove
something
but you to prove optimal bounce as we're
trying you need very very sharp bounds
for all levels of decision trees not
just constant levels but literally all
levels
yeah does it make a difference in the
matrices in kind of these different
layers of this graph
that's not really yeah you can take them
to be all the same yeah
because it needed a very sharp on for
the Fourier spectrum of decision trees
that was proven by shares subscribe
these two things you obtain
the bound we're aiming for for random
various of this problem
okay but this other population because
this maximum moment doesn't Decay for
correlation it can be one
so
so the moral of the story which is going
to be the next slide is sometimes
exact computation is helpful
so
so sometimes even if the distribution
here which is a complicated distribution
because it's enforcing how the pairwise
correlation look like with this hard
amount Matrix yeah
uh you can still compute it exactly this
quantity
and uh
to do this we'll call this very catchy
title that was coined by telegram called
the smart path method
and instead of proving this directly you
will sort of slowly interpolate between
these two distributions
this is where it connects with today's
theme beyond the Boolean Cube I guess uh
but today we are going to go inside the
Boolean Cube
they are slowly interplayed between
these two distributions in some way
and uh so your sort of goal is to show
that as you
interpolate between the uniform
distribution at time 0 to
this correlated distribution at time one
in between you have some other
distribution your quantity your expected
value doesn't change much
so you want the values of the end points
of these two things
we want to show that they are closed but
instead of doing that uh
what telegrams sort of philosophy is
that you can find like a smart path not
a dump path but a smart path where the
derivatives are sort of small along this
path so the derivatives are sort of
close to zero then you don't move much
and you can sort of uh show that the
expected value doesn't change
uh
and how you interplay between them is a
thing we're going to answer
later in the start
so
any questions
so main theorem uh
that sort of part of this talk
just sort of
somehow if you do this interpolation and
try to compute things exactly
then even though the polynomial F has
very very high degree terms all of the
higher degree terms sort of cancel out
and what's left is for k equals 2 K is
the advantage of how we can distinguish
it only depends on the level two free of
it so only on the algor norm of the
level two monomials divided by some
square root of 10.
so this was proven by Iran and I wish I
and for higher K this is proven in my
paper with nikhil
so now the advantage doesn't depend on
high just the level two free weight but
only small number of levels
for instance for k equals three it sort
of depends only between levels three and
six and the contribution progressively
decreases
and for K greater than three sort of uh
depends on the first K Square levels and
K is a constant so it's not a lot
okay
and if you see this Asterix which I
don't know if you can really says
ignoring some lies which I'm telling you
so I've stated the nicest possible
version of this theorem well there's
some log factors that are missing and
this this is not the Fourier weight of f
but the Fourier weight of some any
restriction of f
so but we can Bond it in the same way
so if we followed this so far I think
convey the main message of the stock and
the rest of the talk will be about going
into more into these ideas and how to
scenario
it's awesome just say that you can apply
this to any model that you believe as
small yeah exactly
for example yeah exactly so so all these
curves there will depend on the career
weight here of the spectrum of your
accommodation model so you can basically
use it to prove any separations and
since we know that formulation is easy
for Quantum Computing uh I guess
the more powerful computation more you
can analyze and Boundary Spectrum
competence of patients you can get here
yeah do you know if the K square is
necessary uh yeah so we don't know uh
where the K square is necessary also
means that you can get only the level K
rate for each of these no no we don't
know how to prove it
so this is
for the hardware but it also but it also
works for any dynamated filter Okay so
all you need is the entries of The
Matrix
definitely so the hardware Matrix
Matrix this entries are roughly the same
so that's what it is
foreign
[Music]
and so
you really need my to show that the
matter less and less is equal to
Fahrenheit
and so that's why in this case they all
cancel out so you don't need them so
that's fine and also the contribution
also producing interviews
any more questions
okay so if all I need to knowledge
go into
software insights into these ideas
so let's look at how do you Bound for a
growth of a decision tree
and again I'm not going to go too much
into this sock because it probably
doesn't fit today's theme and I don't
have enough time but there is going to
be talk about this thing in the next
Workshop so
you can come to that if you're
interested
it's quite a non-trivial task to prove
for your growth bounds even for very
simple models
for higher levels basically
so let's look at our decision tree it
has makes the queries it has lab d
and it computes the degree at Deep
polynomial
coefficients in absolute value
and let's just do a very nice thing
let's just do position shorts so and
choose L monomials so just koshy
Schwartz will give us this one
thank you
and as I said before the sums of squares
of all uh
coefficient series at most one so you
get this very trivial bound of entries
it's 12 to that
so it turns out that so far we haven't
really used anything other than the fact
that the function was almost mounted it
turns out that this is roughly close to
the maximal Fourier growth you can have
because even if you consider k-fold
formulation it's a degree Kepler normal
but sort of Fourier growth roughly
matches this up to maybe some Square
different factors
that was very very large quantity uh if
you don't assume anything about your
competition model
can be computed by a very logically
polymer C1
decision trees for level one
I mean it turns out that the Fourier
weight is roughly square root of the
depth so the depth is small this is very
small quantity it's proven by Ryan and
Rocco
in 2007.
for all levels I wish I proved this
round which is
square root D to the L times some poly
log factors which
can be pretty large since n can be two
to the D your depth can be much much
smaller than the number of variables you
have
this bound is pretty good for low levels
but it kind of becomes uh not very good
as you increase l
firstly the optimal Bond was proven by
shared stuff stores and going Wu we sort
of showed that
instead of square root D2 D to L you can
replace it by a square root D Chooser
which gets which is optimal for all
levels
so
the last bone is sort of a very
sophisticated proof kind of requires
very complicated decomposition of your
decision trees and even though it's a
very simple model kind of pretty
challenging to prove
and let me make two remarks about this
first is that all these bonds also holds
for randomized decision trees
there's a randomized decision tree just
a convex combination of classical
decision trees and this quantity sort of
convex in some sense
so all these bounds proven here also
work for randomize also give you
randomization pre-load months
secondly
those two bounds here they also sort of
you can also prove matching lower bounds
maybe ignoring the log dependence which
for even stronger models like parity
decent increase
but we don't know the optimal Bound for
battery decision trees for all levels
and that's a nice open problem if you
want to think about it
although for application to these lower
bounds that we are going to talk about
here uh sort of not needed
small level amount
any questions
I think that's all I'm going to talk
about free growth here and I'm going to
move on to
the thing for today which is Pathways
analysis
give you some flavor of what goes on in
the proof
let's just continue how do you how does
password analysis come into proving your
Bound for the twofold case
so our goal is to distinguish the
uniform distribution from the correlated
distribution by some sort of finding
some sort of interpolating path between
these two distributions
so let me just remind you what the
formulation distribution was
you picked X and Y to be gaussians which
were independent on the left and right
and in between there was some
correlation given by the this entry HIV
it was generated and so if you look at
the covenants Matrix of this gaussian it
sort of looks like this you have
identity in the left and right block
these are the end bit and dimension
identity
and you have hadamard Matrix which has
small entries on the off diagonal blocks
and you round it in some way to the
hypercube plus minus one
this was the foliated distribution
and to interpolate
it would be very useful to view the
uniform Distribution on the hypercube
plus minus one it's being generated in a
similar way
so let's just pick standard gaussian so
2 and dimensional there gaussian which
is independent in all coordinates this
is an each coordinate has various one
and you apply the same process first
sample standard gaussian then you round
it to the hyper queue for instance by
taking sine or whatever you're doing
here
and this generates the uniform
distribution of the hyperte
so these two things look very similar
now
we want to understand
for the expected value sort of looks
like the left and the right cases
now the suggests a very natural way to
interpolate
so you sort of a tiny you sample a you
gaussian whose covariance is the linear
interpolation of the two covariances
Time Zero the covariance is uh
coordinates on the left at time one the
governance is covenants on the right and
it between is some linear combination
which is straightforwardly in a
combination
so DFT is some gaussian and then you
round it again so that gives you some
distribution a sort of interface between
these two things
any questions about what the
distribution is
okay and uh so how do we analyze you
know what happens in this path
and for this is a very nice tool that
comes in it's called gaussian
interpolation
let me explain it a little bit more
generally I give you some examples to
make it concrete because that's probably
more useful
so suppose you have two gaussians X and
Y
you want to interpolate between them by
linearly interpolating their covalences
so at time T I will call the
intermediate gaussian to be U of T okay
the gaussian interpolation formula sort
of describes how the derivative along
this path the time derivative sort of
looks like
it's sort of an expression is sort of a
bit unwieldy but uh so let me try to
help you parse it
the derivative and H here is some
arbitrary function
the derivative here sort of looks like
summation Over All
so it's n dimensional function summation
over all i j there's an M the first
quantity is how the covariance in that
Con in that pair of chordates changed
from the initial to the final
so Sigma final is the final covariance
Sigma initial is the initial covariance
in that end that particular coordinate
the first thing is the covariance
difference and the second thing is the
expected value of the second derivative
so now I mean you might think that okay
all I have done here is like there was
some complicated expectation we want to
compute now related to another
complicated expectation of some
derivative so why is it helpful
sometimes the derivative functions are
well behaved and then you can use it
in the coordinates with covariance
differs is small and then you can get
much more mileage out of this
so let me just give you sort of a
standalone example so illustrate it and
make this a little bit more concrete
the example is uh basic version of
that we are going to prove with this
formula
X and Y we got our gaussians in RN
so they are not standard gaussians they
have some covariance structure but
they're also mean zero
and uh what we're going to assume about
this gaussians is that the variance in
each coordinate is the same so the
diagonal entries of these covariance
matrices are the same
and off diagonal entries of y's are
bigger than octagonal entries of x
so Y is sort of more correlated than x
f of x could be just a standard gaussian
and Y would be you know the gaussian
which is more correlated
says that the expected value of the
maximum of these X
uh
Exiles it's sort of always bigger so the
infinity Norm of the X gaussian and
expectation is always larger than
infinity or Norm of Y
and the interpretation is that the more
correlated is your gaussian sort of the
smaller is expected value
the statement layer
the
very powerful level it's used to compare
different gaussian processes all the
time
you're going to see a very short proof
of this using this passing interpolation
so first of all this Max is not a
differentiable function so let's just
replace it with some sort of soft Max
function just just this log of summation
over e to the beta x i
normally F by 1 over beta so this is
some approximation to the max function
as you increase beta this function
actually converges to the max of the H
coordinate so the maximum coordinate
will give you the most value most
contribution to this
the only thing about this function that
we're going to use is that
considers of diagonal derivatives
a partial database with respect to
different coordinates I and J
then it's it is less than 0 at all
points
if you compute its derivative which I'm
going to do here you can see that this
is true
now let's just try to apply this formula
directly
so we interpolate between these two
gaussians X and Y using this linearly
interpolating the covariance and
the expected value the derivative at a
midpoint is sort of given by this
formula first thing is the difference of
the covariance
and note that the covariance of these
two things the diagonal covariance
entries the difference is zero so they
don't matter
and off diagonal governance entries you
get the difference times the expected
value of the derivative
and we know that the derivative at all
points is
not positive because at one zero
and we know that the Y is more
correlated so this quantity is at least
zero
basically this derivative is always
negative or not positive
so as time goes on your
it's like a monotonically decreasing
function and this value at the end is
smaller than the function value at the
end is smaller than the function value
in the beginning so expected value of f
of x which is the value at the beginning
is sort of larger than the expected
value of y
this is one simple example of this thing
and uh I don't know how many of you were
in the reading group but you can use it
to prove sort of very powerful results
uh you can use it to prove gaussian
concentration
you can use it to prove that's gaussian
correlation inequality which was open
for more than 50 years just by using
this formula with little bit of calculus
so hopefully this example makes it a
little bit more concrete how do we use
it and in this example of two-fold
correlation
again
something to gaussians at the left hand
uh right and you're rounding it by
applying some function we are again
doing this linear interpolation
so he can apply this formula directly
let me note that the difference of the
covariance and the diagonal is sort of
zero because the diagonals are the same
so all once you subtract these two
matrices
all entries are 1 over square root and
magnitude
very different in the covariance is one
over square root 10. and with a little
bit of calculation which I'm not going
to show here you sort of relate the
second derivatives of this edge here
which is the function f after you apply
the surrounding thing to your gaussian
to the second derivatives of your
function f and we enter some
restrictions and this sort of uh gives
you this sort of flow down
okay so now the Fourier weight is small
you get a lower bound on your
classical model
okay any questions
so I've hidden something I mean some
details here which I don't want to
explain and if you see this it's quickly
Arrow that's what it will mean
with the second derivatives
you've seen earlier the secondary
interior relates to this yeah so
yeah so the fully a bit uh there's a sum
of coefficients of the second level
which I said before is the uh values and
derivative the second derivatives
evaluated at zero that's how these two
quantities are related
so this is good for any jobs here with
small correlations yeah
but you can use it with academics
function or if you want to use the
discontinuous function you can use some
Edo processor calculus
okay for example
but it's the is
we're going to talk on a few minutes
about the threefold the entire level
case because there's some details here
which are very annoying to explain but
uh
let me try just very briefly
so again uniform distribution was the
uniform distribution here and let me re
help you recall the formulated
distribution
gaussians
to Independent copies of the gaussians X
a and Y B the same covariance structure
as before the 2 4K and taking the point
wise product X will be the same as X
this x z will be the same as this Z
and in the middle you will just take the
point wise products of these two things
so the distribution here is like product
of gaussians and then you apply some
rounding to it
and again as before it would be helpful
to view the uniform distribution as
being generated in exactly the same way
by the same process
now you take products of standard
gaussians is to standard graph since x a
and b z and again you round it
and what you want to understand here
another goal is to sort of interplay
between these two things
our goal is to sort of understand this
function X and the Y is like the
pointwise product of these two things
and Z so this multilinear function
applied on this thing these two things
and how the expectations under these two
distributions on the left and right they
differ
now the first problem is
when you take the 0.5 product of two
gaussians it's not a gaussian anymore so
we can't really directly use substance
interpolation
the next best thing you can do is like
you can view this as a another
polynomial an x a b and c because you're
just doing some substitution you get the
problem of the left
I'm writing it differently because they
thought the derivatives of these
polynomials might behave very
differently so that's why you need to be
careful about this
but now with this p
you have a function of a gaussian so you
can hope to interpolate
if you do this uh interpretation I
showed you before just one dimensional
thing
sort of doesn't turn out to be very
helpful for reasons that uh can't
explain
so
what what you do is like you interplay
between this red X a and this green XA
by one pad and this y DZ in this red and
green bz with another path so sort of
like a two dimensional linear
interpolation
but parameters by different things
because you have X and there is
if you get a and b separately then the
problem cannot be harder yeah okay
yeah so what's the best way to explain
it but somehow yeah in this distribution
you're taking the point wise product and
that's what's hiding the correlation so
you have to look at all of them together
uh even to tell what the value is
oh sorry it should be BNC sorry yeah
again I'm going to be very sketchy about
it interpolation
you will get fourth order derivatives
because you are doing these two
different paths in terms of X A and B
and z
and now the whole challenge is to relate
it to the derivatives of your function f
and the point here is that since you're
taking pointwise products if your
indices sort of match up then you get a
third derivative of f if Z and K are the
same here because you can combine those
two terms together to get a y variable
but if they don't match up then
how do you bound those terms we need
more cancellations there
so the goal is to sort of show that
somehow
uh the expectations differ by something
that only depends on Co order
derivatives maybe the six four
derivatives
so somehow you need to get more
cancellations and
if you try to
leverage another tool that I'm going to
tell you about we can show that such
terms also cancel out and give you these
high order terms that decay
exponentially
again it's
not easy to explain this because there's
a lot of indices flying around when you
try to write it down so I'm going to
tell you what the tool we use is and
just give you sort of a standalone
example let's sort of illustrates the
phenomena
the two layers one very unique property
of the gaussian distribution called
gaussian integration by parts
buying formula if you want to compute
the expected value
of
this gaussian F is a function of n
variables and G1 through G and are
gaussians and g0 is also jointly
gaussian with them
and they are not standard gaussians
they're arbitrarily correlated
and you want to compute this expectation
on the left which is expected value of G
0 times F of G
some comparative quantity but you can
still compute it in terms of
expected value the sum overall
correlations of g0 had with each of the
coordinates times the expected value of
the partial derivatives given by I
so this is the formula okay let me try
to give you an example just to make
sense of it
and this formula is really useful if g0
the correlation of g0 with each of the
gis is kind of small and you have a
bound on the derivatives because then
you can see that this gives you a nicely
Behavior
the correlation between g0 and Gi
because entry is just one over square
root 10.
we want to compute the expected value of
this monomial which is the product of
all the G zeros
by this formula this is one over square
root n which is the covariance and the
expected value of all the derivatives
which is the term where you remove just
g0 and GI basically
right here
in this term there is no G zero that
appears it's only a function of the rest
of the gaussian
so all you have done here is you've
traded off your derivative for a one
over square root and factor and
essentially that's the same phenomena
that happens if you try to analyze this
three-fold formulation case
and let me just as an aside mentioned
it's very nice identity that you can
prove using discussion integration by
parts I'll leave this as exercise
so the gaussian distribution is uniquely
determined by covariance matrix and it's
mean first assume the mean is zero
so you should be able to compute all his
moments just in terms of the pairwise
moments because that's the covariance
entries and this mixed formula tells you
how to do this so suppose we have two k
gaussians
uh uh then the expected moment of this
thing is sort of given by you take any
perfect matching of these 2K coordinates
and you consider those pairwise
covariances and add them up and that
gives you this moment so this is what
calls vix formula
or israeli's theorems used in physics a
lot
so you can prove it very easily just by
induction and using this repeatedly
for me that was some
we got something out of it so let me
summarize
we saw that sort of
uh distinguishing Advantage for a
computation Model F only depends on the
low level footy weights it was the high
level Fourier weights cancel out if you
try to do this pathwise way
and now you can get stronger and
stronger lower bowels just by analyzing
the Fourier spectrum of your bullet
function
sort of uh you know two important
Concepts that we saw like Fourier growth
in Python analysis that came in proving
the surbound hopefully you got a sense
of how they are used here
and I mean they have many other
applications as I said free growth is
usually learning theory pseudonymous
analysis and you know
marketing sampling and Ultra company
you'll see in this Workshop
so let me just include this sounds
these are not open problems but open
directions Maybe
careful formation is a very natural
problem it's sort of this talk we just
looked at Quantum classical separations
we can also use it to separate Quantum
complexity classes
uh like Oracle separations
and there's possible many open problems
there related to that
that you can try to explore with these
methods
the second is if you want to prove
better and better separations between
Quantum and classical
uh all you need to do is now to analyze
Fourier growth even low level four
growth of your computation model
and this will give us better
preparations
Earthwise analysis is a very big field
on its own and for this I will just end
with this code by Leonard gross who's
the one who introduced hyperconductivity
in the 70s or something
how are you how far can you go with
koshy shots and integration by parts and
you can go very very far
thank you
[Applause]
can you ask questions
you've seen some
uh
this method to
well kind of polarizing random book is
sort of like a discretized coffee
process so kind of similar
ization matters there because you need
to really have a common seed length you
have and how quickly Convergys so
Alternatives construction for the uh
so the construction that for fractional
prgs that only uses second level yeah it
was basically based yeah it's MPGs
yeah that's true
yeah so you can use this yeah as well
okay I guess to transfer some prv those
formation problem but I think you really
have to discretized
foreign
and maybe one thing I should say the K4
case is sort of similar that they find
similarly as you can imagine
people don't have questions such a
horrible talk I don't have any questions
[Music]
again
[Applause]
we'll be back after